So you thought this was a dead meme did you? no
no meme is dead until I say so. My name is PewDiePie. I'm a level 5 mad lad (epicness
You don't believe me huh?
I'm so mad. I drink monster energy drink.
From a glass
Let's review some other mad lads to bring back life into mad lads
Please if anyone ever
Refers to any of my work as a "meh-meh". They they will be immediately blocked. This is not a joke
Look at Brian here with a soy-ish (?) looking face
Don't do it Brian
That's too crazy don't challenge her/him or whatever hope this turns into a meme
MAD LAD!!!!
You know what this toast goes out to you Brian. Namaste
That's some fine monster energy drink
Y'all ever just say he-eh and eat it with the shell. Okay, you can't eat it with the shell
You could die. That's dangerous
You can't digest paper like food everyone knows that
Is he okay, is he
Okay, please we need to report this to make sure that other kids don't see this and do the same thing
This is not a joke. Just kidding. I actually don't care
Mad lad...
I Saw a post on here about a guy who had irrational hate for odd numbers
So he upvotes posts to make them even so now I upvote even post in order to make them odd and spite him
MAD
LAH-
That's crazy. He's gonna get super angry.
I saw a Bahb in real life, ask me anything
Your mom doesn't count
yes...
But your does
If this post
No, no, no, no, no, no. No if this post gets 30,000 likes I will drink this glass of water. Don't do it
Hey guys, guess what? I have a girlfriend now
Damn, and I kiss and love her ha ha april fools you idiots
I still very much alone.
You dumb F's... lol
MAD!!!
Watching an anti weed documentary (while stoned)
Someone hold the camera
You can't do that, you can't just watch an anti weed documentary while stoned
Do you understand? That's so irresponsible mad lad?
Some people are just crazy out there!
What are they gonna do next?
Permabanning anyone who calls me PewDiePie
That's right
That's right, motherf-
That's right. Looking sharp there pewds
MAD LAD!!!!
Also note how I didn't say PewDiePie. I said pewds, I'm two steps ahead of anyone
That's a even...thinking that they're a mad lad.
The graffiti in my hometown is getting out of control
"Swear words"
I like this guy. I like this guy. He's like
This will probably make it to the mad rad?, mad lad subreddit
And Pewdiepie will review it and he can't review memes with swear words in it or else
His video will get demonetized so I'm gonna be responsible here
Thank you
Appreciate you
All right, What do we have here
Youtube link scribbled into stone. It leads to Rick Astley's "Never gonna give you up"
Mad lad!
Absolute mad lad!
How can you be so crazy? How do you even think of this stuff?
You gotta be completely cuckoo out of buku
ad go ahead. Skip this ad me: Okay.
All right, this is just too far
This is too I have to be responsible here because if you hit skip ad then that means I don't get as much revenue
Unless you watch it thirty Seconds through okay
So please be responsible here
Don't take this too far. Okay, my little brother edited Mia Khalifa
Into who is that into his bald photos and both my parents have come
Commented on how nice the photo is. Oh, what's a great picture you have here?
You finally made a girlfriend
Guy lives next to airport. Painted this on roof to confuse passengers as they fly overhead
He lives in Milwaukee. That's it. That is Cleveland
my god
This man needs to be arrested and sending to Mad Lad
Party town cuz that's where epic people go like this man
friend request had been idling in his inbox for like six years
But at last I am finally able to conduct the sickest burn in American history
His name is Brian. Best Brian worse accepted your friend request
Brian best - Brian worst
circuit
This is the power of mad lads. This is the strength that it contains. Are you able to handle it?
I don't think so
hahaha just pranked my flatmate by opening up his pack of eggs and
Rearranging them so he won't know which eggs are which oh my god, like, oh, no, no, sorry
But now I have to pick the pause button guys. Don't do this
Think about the person that you are dealing with
Sometimes pranks can be funny because both parties are laughing afterwards
If that doesn't happen, it's not a prank. It's worse. It's bullying, you know, y- no. it's worse is
Mean, no, it's worse. It's really bad
Is there if there was a worldwide game of hide-and-seek. Where would you hide? not telling you.
Whoa, whoa
Whoa, okay. Please hit the pause button right now. Don't actually do it. That would be crazy
You hit the pause button didn't you? I- I knew you were a mad lad. I knew you were a m- again
Man gets two years in prison for claiming he created Kung Fu Panda
Can we get an F in the chat guys? This is people that push the limit
oh man, lad to see where he can take them and
Society wants to shut us down, but two years in prison, that'll mean nothing because people will know
That I'm the one that created Kung Fu Panda 2 when you eat cereal do you use milk in it? I use water. Damn
damn
Damn
Mad lad mmh. Damn
Damn some people are just hard
Some people are just hard. They've been through things
They've seen things: It changes things, things have changed for people
People are hard. So am I just
Kidding this whole ligma trend is so stupid
True only so good these people find it funny. Oh
It's coming guys hit pause right now, what's sugandese? Sugandese nuts. Ah,
AAAA
If if only that would happen if that was me I would just quit YouTube because I'd've officially peaked. Hey guys
Do me a favor. What is this Pokemon called? Rhydon on my ass!!!
bill
What are you gonna what are you gonna do smash like on this video? Buh! you don't have the balls
You don't have the balls. Whatever what it takes. I think that's enough mad lad for one day
Thank you guys for smashing like on this video
Remember we added the merch for four or more days in case you missed it in case you're an absolute man land and buys
Remember we added the merch for four or more days in case you missed it in case you're an absolute mad lad and buys
One of each item, that would be crazy
Don't do that that would support the channel and give me more revenue. That would be crazy
That would be insane. You can't just do that.
Nah.
Alright, goodbye
Remember we added the merch for four or more days in case you missed it in case you're an absolute mad lad and buys
Like and subscribe